this Cube can help you think in four
dimensions it's called a knicker cube
and you can't tell if it's facing
forwards or is a mirror image facing
backwards as you stare at it you will
see both you'll perceive it turning into
its mirror image and back again it may
even seem like a continuous twinkling
rotation but there is no way to rotate a
shape to get its Mirror Image at least
not without going to a higher Dimension
to mirror flip a 1D shape we need to use
the second dimension to mirror flip a 2d
shape we need to use the third dimension
to mirror flip a 3D shape we would need
to use the fourth dimension if you see
it continuously change perspective then
perhaps you are producing a 4D
phenomenon in your mind which is why